[Music]
this is all of the trash that I've
produced in the past three years when I
say that people think that I'm crazy or
that I'm lying or they'll ask me
questions like hey so how do you wipe
your butt
I live a zero-waste lifestyle and I have
for the past three years now zero waste
that's a pretty big idea right so let me
define it for you to me living zero
waste means that I don't make any trash
so no sending anything to landfill no
sending anything in a garbage can and no
spitting gum on the ground and walking
away right no trash this is a big
concept and this all started when I was
an environmental study student at NYU my
senior year I was taking a course called
the environmental studies capstone
course which is essentially the
culminating course that all
environmental study students need to
take in order to go out into the world
and make it a more sustainable place
well there was a girl in this class and
every class she would have this big
plastic bag with a plastic clamshell
fill of food a plastic fork and knife a
plastic water bottle the plastic bag of
chips and she would eat all of this and
then class after class would just throw
it in the trash now this was really
frustrating because here we were these
environmental study students trying to
make the world a better place and there
she was throwing all this stuff into the
garbage one day after class feelings
still particularly upset about watching
her throw everything away I went home to
make dinner and I opened my fridge and
noticed something that I had never seen
before every single thing in my fridge
was in one way or another
packaged in plastic and I couldn't
believe it you know I was getting so mad
at this girl for making so much plastic
trash and it turns out that I was just
as bad I was that girl and so I made a
decision in that moment I was going to
stop using plastic well quitting plastic
not so easy of a thing right when you
think about your everyday life you wake
up in the morning you go into the
bathroom and you brush your teeth
what is your toothbrush made out of
plastic what does your toothpaste
probably packaged in your face wash your
moisturizer your contact solution so
many things that are in our everyday
lives come packaged in plastic and so I
realized that if I was going to move
away from plastic the only way that I
was going to be able to do that was to
learn how to make my products myself
well I don't know about you but I
certainly didn't know how to make
deuteron and didn't have the recipe just
kind of hanging out in my back pocket
and so I realized that I had to do some
research and while I was doing research
online I came across a blog called the
zero waste home started by a woman named
Fayed Johnson who's a wife and mother of
two kids out in Mill Valley California
and the four of them live a completely
zero waste life when I learned about
baya and her family my mind was
completely blown I thought that I was
doing the best thing that I could for
the planet by not using any plastic but
the idea that I didn't have to produce
any trash was so empowering and so
inspiring and it made perfect sense
right because I was this environmental
study student I cared about the
environment studied sustainability
talked about sustainability protested
for sustainability but I realized that I
wasn't actually implementing any of
those values into my day-to-day life and
so I made the decision to go zero waste
so let me break it down for you and tell
you about some of the things that I did
in order to make this transition a
little easier the first thing that I did
was I stopped buying
packaged food so instead of going into
the store and buying things packaged in
paper and glass and plastic I started
bringing my own jars and bags to the
store to fill with bulk or package free
items I also started buying my fruit and
vegetables from the farmers market so a
package free the second thing that I
started doing was I started making all
of my own products before I started
living this lifestyle my boyfriend at
the time used to brush his teeth using
baking soda and I thought he was
probably the grossest person in the
entire world right there's no way that
you could possibly get your teeth
cleaned using something like baking soda
it's gross well fast-forward and it
turns out that the first product that I
made was toothpaste made with baking
soda so over time I started making all
of my own products when I would run out
of something instead of going to the
store and buying a new one I would learn
how to make it myself so when I would
run out of lotion and learned how to
make it myself run out of deodorant
learn how to make it myself over time
all of the things that I had previously
purchased were now ones that I made
myself the third thing that I started
doing was shopping secondhand so instead
of buying new clothing and putting new
waste into the waste cycle I would buy
things that were totally recycled
secondhand so not making any new trash
the fourth thing that I did was I
downsized so I focused on having only
the things that were truly necessary and
that I really needed well this was
really really hard because I'm the kind
of person who's really sentimental and I
can tell you as to why a toothpick needs
to be in my life but after I really got
through that process and I completely
downsized I realized that I had so many
fewer things in my life my home was less
cluttered and everything was easier to
clean and when you have fewer things you
realize that you take better care of
them right so when you take better care
of your things you don't have this
mentality like oh if I don't want this
anymore I'll just throw it out and get a
new thing later
no I only
had a few things and so I took care of
them and wasn't sending anything to
landfill all this must sound pretty
difficult I assure you it's not that
hard I'm just an average lazy person and
I wouldn't live this lifestyle if it was
difficult in fact the benefits of living
this lifestyle far outweigh any of the
negatives that you could imagine the
first benefit is that I saved money so I
saved money when I buy my food and the
products and when I make my own products
because I'm not paying for the embedded
cost of packaging so things are cheaper
I'm also saving money by shopping
completely secondhand because secondhand
clothing is usually less expensive than
new clothing I'm also saving money
because I've downsized and so I don't go
shopping all the time now and you know
just buy things on impulse I only have
what I really need the second benefit is
that I eat better when I go shopping now
I don't have the option to buy processed
food products package free and so now my
diet consists of things like fresh fruit
and vegetables or bulk you know grains
and nuts that I buy with my jars and my
bags and so when you eat better you feel
better I've noticed that over these past
few years my weight has stabilized I
have more energy I need less sleep and
when you're eating better and you feel
better and you save money you're happier
but besides those things I'm happier
because for the first time in my life
I'm living in direct alignment with my
values and why is this important right
waist
well waist is a really big problem in
fact the average American person
produces approximately 4.4 pounds of
trash per person per day over the course
of a year that's like taking 8 and a
half of your best friends and throwing
them in the trash
don't do that it's not nice so if you
care about your friends and you don't
want to throw them away and you think
that it's possible for you to possibly
reduce how much trash you're producing I
have three simple steps for you the
first step is to actually look at your
trash and understand what it is because
you can't solve a problem of having a
lot of waste until you know what it is
so when I did this exercise I realized
that I had three main sources of trash
the first was food packaging and so I
learned how to shop in bulk or package
free the second was product packaging
and so I learned how to make all my own
products and the third was organic food
waste and so I learned how to compost
and just by identifying those three
sources of waste and eliminating them I
had reduced my trash by about 90% the
second thing that I like to suggest is
picking at the low-hanging fruit so
doing little things one time changes in
your everyday life that have a large
scale and long-term positive impact this
includes things like using a reusable
bag instead of a plastic or paper bag or
using a stainless steel or glass water
bottle instead of buying plastic water
bottles over the course of you know
however long you realize that these
little changes actually add up and make
a big difference the third thing that I
like to suggest is the DIY or actually
learning how to make your products
yourself now I absolutely love doing
this because when you go to a store and
you have to buy products you kind of
have to settle and accept them as they
are right if you don't like the way they
smell too bad if you don't like the way
they feel sorry if you don't like what
they're packaged in you don't have a
choice
but for me since I make all my own
products if I don't like the way they
smell
I change the scent if I don't like the
ingredients in them I change it if I
don't like the packaging it's my choice
and so by making my own products I have
complete control over what I'm putting
in my body now I started living this
lifestyle while I was still in college
and when I graduated I
had a real job a real-person job in
sustainability which is exactly what
you'd think I'd want to be doing right
well at the same time I was still
running my blog trashes for tossers and
I noticed that I was getting a recurring
question and it was something like this
dear Lauren I absolutely love the
products that you're making and I too
want truly natural products but because
of life
family friends bla bla bla bla bla I
just don't have time to make them myself
do you have any products that I can go
out and buy that are equivalent
thanks to your health lots of love
person XYZ so I went to stores and I
started looking at products and while I
found that there were beauty products
that were reminiscent of the ones that I
was making myself I didn't notice the
same trend for cleaning products when I
looked at the ingredients of cleaning
products even the natural cleaning
products contained ingredients that were
really harmful things that were at
carcinogenic and endocrine disruptive
you know when I looked into it further
I learned that cleaning product
manufacturers aren't even legally
required to disclose the ingredients of
their products on the product packaging
and so many when we go and buy a product
we're at the complete mercy of the
company hoping that they have our best
interest in mind I feel that we as
consumers have a right to products that
are transparent and that aren't bad for
us and so I started thinking about my
own products the ones that I've been
making for years that are safe and
effective and have ingredients that I
used to do things like brush my teeth or
make salad dressing and I realized that
I had an opportunity and so I quit my
job and started a company because I feel
like we as human beings have a right to
products that are safe for our homes and
our bodies and the environment I get
comments all the time that I'm doing
this for attention but I live this
lifestyle for myself I would never tell
anyone how to live or how much trash
that they should produce I just want to
provide tools through my blog and my
business for people who like me
want to reduce how much trash they're
producing I live a zero-waste lifestyle
because to me it's the best way I know
how to live a life that aligns with
everything that I believe in and what's
the point right I'm just one person what
difference can I make the point is
simple I want to be remembered for the
things that I did while I was on this
planet and not for the trash that I left
behind thank you
[Applause]